we are spending a day in the life of a
Sports Illustrated cover girl you
changed so many lives today I'm happy to
be the Trailblazer
but come on man come on the average
sized American woman is the 14 instead
of plus-size Ashley calls herself sexy
curvalicious making history as part of a
trio of covers along with Haley Clausen
and Rhonda Rousey Ashley began her day
by inviting us along as she faced a
whirlwind of press
good morning et it's just before 8:00
a.m. and I am getting sexy and ready for
my serious radio interview she and Haley
made the rounds and Ashley revealed Tyra
Banks was the first to congratulate her
she was like you have officially made
history and I have made history when I
was on the cover of Sports Illustrated
and now you have and I'm really excited
for you to take this and make it a big
opportunity for yourself these two had a
day full of criss-crossing wintery
Manhattan they mingled with fans at a
swim City event where Haley kind of
realized her cover might be career
changing I mean I'm gonna become a name
which is pretty amazing
it's kind of it's gonna matter more
they're gonna be more interested also in
the issue Hannah Davis snorkeling in
Tahiti the future mrs. Derek Jeter tells
us when she walks down that aisle she'll
be wearing a Vera Wang gown we're sort
of in the preliminary stages I don't
know if I'll give too many details
before the actual day but yeah I'm very
excited that she's designing to dress
well kind of held true to not giving up
to as much information because she
didn't give a date for the wedding she
says they're still working it out Oh
Derek Jeter doesn't mess around you know
they're gonna keep that close to the
vest